Welcome back everyone it's Charlie Ben Affleck
was talking a lot about his version of the Batman
movie deleted scenes what was going on with all
the villains so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos recently Zack Snyder just held
another Snyder con he screened all of his Snyder
Vs DC movies Man of Steel Batman v Superman the
Justice League Snyder cut and revealed a bunch
more deleted scenes and Concepts along with actors
from the movies like Ray Fisher and Ben Affleck
coming I just did a completely separate video for
all the Justice League Snyder cut deleted scenes
in his plans for the sequels like Justice League
2 Justice League three so I'll link that video
at the end of this and down in the description
below this video is mostly about Ben Affleck's
version of the Batman movie that he was talking
about during the convention Ben Affleck attended
and talked a lot about his version of the Batman
movie that he had been making up until he left
the project in 2017 around the time they started
talking to Matt Reeves about doing his version
of the Batman movie with Robert Pattinson the
main villain of the movie would have been Joe
manginiello's Deathstroke from the Justice
League in addition to a number of other regular
Batman villains this is in talking about that
there were a number of them that I was kind
of exploring and the plans were to you know
like I mean make interesting nuanced complex
characters uh in particular to the character
mentioned and I didn't really I I I kind of feel
like either you do I mean I'm just gonna get into
my own preference here which is but either you
do like a kind of massive kind of one villain
that is so formidable you just can't imagine how
it is that your protagonist is going to be able
to to overcome it or you have to sort of really
populate kind of uh like you know these you know
like you know the Injustice like these big group
villains where you get to have all these different
characters so I was at the time really trying to
kind of hone in and focus on that character and
um get into to depth and and detail about it to
make him seem as as impressive as I as I felt
like there was the opportunity to do um and
I that that's the only detail I have for you
when he talks about the difference in the types
of villains from the movie there were a couple
different versions of the movie that they had
planned on making that Ben Affleck had turned
in through Scripps it started out as more of a
Raid Redemption style more self-contained movie
with Batman fighting his way through different
levels of Arkham Asylum I think it was a 2015
when he first started working on the movie and
on each floor each level of Arkham he would
have encountered different villains that he'd
captured previously and put in Arkham fairly
simple premise Batman just running a gauntlet of
his most dangerous villains all coming back to
haunt him as he tries to fight his way down to the
maximum security levels of Arkham to get the Joker
his other most dangerous villains but the final
version of that movie when most people talk about
Ben Affleck's version of the Batman movie they're
talking about the Batman versus Deathstroke movie
there was a lot of concept art that was released
from that version of the movie too just because
it was the final version that he was going to
start filming showing Batman's new bat suit
you remember the test footage that Ben Affleck
revealed of Deathstroke here this footage was
actually for his Batman movie it wasn't for Batman
maybe Superman or Justice League or anything like
that that's how far along they got and they were
shooting test footage for special effects and four
Deathstroke's costume they got pretty far along in
pre-production Joe Manganiello had been hyping it
up for a while Ben Affleck had been working on the
movie like I said since around 2015 when Batman v
Superman was still in production because they had
plotted out this giant plan for how all the DC
movies were going to work within the Snyder verse
this was when they were still doing three Justice
League movies they had all these other spin-offs
playing you probably remember the different slates
that they had announced they had initially planned
to film and release Ben Affleck's Batman movie so
that it would come out right after the Justice
League movie with delays that would have been
around spring 2018 based on how long it takes
to get sequels out we probably would have seen
a couple sequels to that Ben Affleck Batman movie
by now too but that was before the studio changed
plans for Zack Snyder's Justice League Trilogy
before he was forced to leave the project after
the tragic death of his daughter so you can see
some of the concept art of Batman vs Deathstroke
during that movie with his use of gadgets love
all the Batman gadgets the difference in the final
version of his movie is that instead of a more
self-contained Raid Redemption type of story it
would have been more of a globe trotting James
Bond style big Batman versus Deathstroke movie
with more of a focus just on Batman vs Deathstroke
as a much more formidable villain as opposed to
him facing a ton of lesser villains one right
after the other that's why during his panel
he said he was toying with a couple different
concepts like facing a bunch of lesser villains
like he says the Injustice society that gets into
some other scenes that I'll talk about in a second
too there were a lot of scenes during the Justice
League Snyder cut that were meant to set up the
Ben Affleck Batman Solo movie one of them was all
the Injustice Society talk and that was going into
the Justice League sequels as well too setting up
that stuff but the other idea as he said was him
going with a much more formidable overarching
villain that was going to be Joe managinello's
Deathstroke so when you re-watch the Justice
League Snyder cut Zack Snyder confirmed this
too all the Batman the Deathstroke scenes at the
very end of the movie the post credit scene Were
Meant to set up the Ben Affleck Batman movie as
well as Justice League 2 in Justice League three
in the Snyder cut version of the movie now this
isn't in the Whedon cut so forget about the weed
and cut in the Snyder version of the movie in the
post credits Deathstroke breaks Lex Luthor out of
Arkham Asylum they Rendezvous on his yacht and
part of Deathstroke's payment for breaking Lex
out of prison in addition to a bunch of money was
that Lex Luthor would give Deathstroke Batman's
secret identity he told him that Batman
was Bruce Wayne but if you want the Batman
here is something that can help you his name is
Bruce Wayne Deathstroke was going to use that
knowledge to systematically tear down Batman's
life destroy Bruce Wayne's life his public life
inseparately destroy Batman's life going after
all of his business interests as Bruce Wayne
using his secret identity against him and the
idea was Deathstroke wanted to torture Batman
slowly kill him slowly make him suffer so much
and I believe in the Ben Affleck Batman version
of events it was going to be the death of Grant
Wilson not Jericho but I'm not totally sure about
that part here's where we get to the nightmare
post-credits scene though because by those events
like at that part of the timeline Deathstroke was
working with Batman in the original timeline for
the release of all these movies their plans you
have to remember Ben Affleck's Batman movie would
have been released between the Justice League
sequels so we'd see the events of Zack Snyder's
Justice League then the Batman movie would come
out then Justice League two and then Justice
League three with a couple other spin-offs and
sequels for other characters between those the
Batman vs Deathstroke Ark is told out of
order so you'd find out about the death of
Deathstroke's son after it's happened they fight
each other during the Batman movie I don't think
they would have totally thrown Batman under the
bus on this one Deathstroke would have ultimately
understood Batman wasn't responsible for his son's
death they call a truce effectively even though he
still doesn't like Batman then Justice League
2 happens Superman's Fallen under dark side's
control because the anti-life equation the death
of Lois Lane the forces of Apocalypse with the
now evil Superman turn the world into a glorified
mining Colony for Darkseid then the timeline plays
out in a way that leads to the nightmare future
which we saw in that post-credits scene and by
that time Deathstroke The Joker several flash
villains the Batman villains are all working
together with the heroes the surviving Justice
League members to stop Darkseid free Superman of
his control in their fighting a losing battle the
Earth has already been scorched basically which
is when Batman and Cyborg and the Flash complete
their time travel plans to send the flash back
in time through the speed force to warn Batman
about Darkseid paying off the scene from Batman v
Superman they have largely covered those events
in Justice League 3 where in the new timeline
like after they're able to save Lois Lane all the
heroes are able to defeat Darkseid successfully
and save Superman from falling under the anti-life
equation talking about the Joker character Zack
Snyder revealed that there was a bunch of
untold story that he planned on doing a bunch
of backstory between what happened with Joker the
dead Robin in Batman before the events of Batman v
Superman he explained it was similar to the events
of Batman death in the family from the comics with
Joker killing Robin but it was a different version
of Robin this version of the Dead Robin was meant
to be the Dick Grayson version not the Jason Todd
version like the comics but the funny thing is
that when he was explaining this Joker vs Batman
vs Robin like him killing Robin he said that he
didn't want to reveal too much because he might
do that in some upcoming story so a lot of people
were just like what does that mean is he gonna do
a new DC project at some point or is he gonna do a
comic book or how is he gonna tell that story and
it just sounds like a Never Say Never situation
because Zack Snyder James Gunn are pretty tight
even though right now Zack Snyder is mostly busy
doing his Rebel Moon movies in the sequels to
that because there'll be sequels and he's trying
to build out that Universe for Netflix what's
happening now is that Ben Affleck is showing up
in The Flash movie it's still meant to be after
the events of the Justice League Snyder cut he
makes the flash his flash ring and is serving as
kind of a mentor for him as the flash continues
working at the ccpd like you see in the Flash
comics with them doing a version of Flashpoint
where flash comes up with the idea that he can
travel into the past and try and save his mother
and they're essentially using that to reboot the
DC Universe into the James Gunn version of the
Gods and Monsters version of the DCU as they're
calling it now James Gunn did say that the new
crossover Batman like the new Justice League
crossover Batman is going to be a completely
new actor that they haven't cast yet and he's
going to debut in Batman brave in the Bold in
the Robert Pattinson Matt Reeves version of the
Batman is going to be else worlds as far as I know
Ben Affleck has said that he's not coming back but
the funny thing is that he just did an interview
for The Flash movie saying that it was the most
perfect version of Batman that he's ever done and
he kind of wants to come back a little bit after
seeing how good he was in that movie he's a little
tongue-in-cheek when he's talking about that like
he's kind of joking when he's saying about coming
back but I think the whole idea is that Never Say
Never And he could always come back it's the same
thing with Henry Cavill Superman James Gunn said
that even though he's doing sort of like a year
two version of Superman with a younger version of
the character and they'll recast a much younger
actor he did say Henry Cavill did say that he
could come back in the future they just didn't
say what and I think that's meant to be more
of an else worlds crisis on infinite Earth's
twist and they'll just say that all the Snyder vs
movies like all these characters when they come
back will be from a different Universe it's just
a much cleaner way to have them come back and it
be explained because some of the actors from the
Snyder verse will continue in the new movies and
they could just say that their alternate universe
versions and just blame it on Flashpoint like just
blame the flash for everything messing with all
the timelines but let me know in the comments if
Ben Affleck's Batman does come back as a cameo
in some Future movie in the distant future
how do you want that to go down like what movie
do you want it to happen in how do you want them
to bring those characters back really it just
feels like a Multiverse crisis on infinite
Earth's Style movie is The Logical way to pull
that off the funny thing about that is that
they were actually building up to that before
the James Gunn Reba before James Lim was hired
they're planned for the next 10 years was to work
up to a crisis on infinite Earth's movie that was
when Henry Cavill was still talking about coming
back and changing all these plans like quitting
The Witcher making all these other plans for other
projects He was working on a lot of that happened
under the assumption that he was going to be busy
filming new Superman movies like they were still
planning on making Man of Steel 2 at that point
there will be some Henry Cavill Superman in The
Flash movie like he's not completely out of that
movie you can click here for the latest trailer
I talk about a little bit during that video and
click here for that new Henry Cavill Warhammer
trailer because he's going to be doing a big
Warhammer series and Warhammer movies now too
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!